wir müssen diese personen irgendwie
steuer und können dabei auf der tastatur
die taste w und p benutzen
das heißt ja nicht dass beispielsweise
einfach mal cool drücke was macht der da
jetzt kann ich auch wir drücken und dann
seht ihr der g 0,3 meter aber die
website mund hat uns auf und sagt
everyone is winner
ich würde sagen ich versuche es erstmal
raus so schön wie das ganze überhaupt
funktioniert also wir haben und wie sind
die zickig schenkel schenkel also tue
und wie für die schenkel und p für die
carls also für die waden sind das glaube
ich das heißt wenn ich drücke seht ihr
schon geht er so ein stückchen zurück wo
wir sind wir sind das ist nicht dein
ernst minus 1,2 meter ich super das
heißt ich musste wahrscheinlich nach
vorne nehmen ihn in die nähe kommen muss
nach vorne du musst davor hatten 30
meter ich weiß nicht wie das ganze
funktionieren soll also wie okay wir
sind auf jeden fall schon mal drüber das
heißt ich nehme jetzt hier genau jetzt
wieder und wer so ein bisschen europa in
gott 09 meter ist auf jeden fall high
score bisher
nee ist es gar nicht er steht da schon
richtig in startposition das heißt
erstmal so genau das heißt wer mich
erstmal ausfallschritt gemacht jetzt
nach vorne genau und jetzt aber so nach
vorne
dieses spiel ist so bescheuert
zunächst erstmal kuh drücken damit das
linke bein nach vorne kommt es mir das
rechte bein es ist ja glaub ich das
heißt jetzt p und jetzt wen ab alles was
über null das ist für mich schon eine
glanzleistung also wir nehmen wieder die
gleiche taktik erst mal nach vorne damit
wir das bein haben jetzt drücken damit
drücken damit er dass er beiden erstmal
anzieht und dann gehen die so nimmt er
denn sein linkes bein nicht mit nach
vorne gedrückt und dann wäre das andere
bein
das war der erste schritt also genau
dann op und jetzt das das sieht doch
immer so schmerzhaft aus wieder denn auf
dem boden fällt
[Musik]
komm junge erst mal cool jetzt und dann
weg da kann es sein dass das ganze spiel
einfach nur eine glückssache ist
außerdem ist mein fuß weiter als mein
highscore ich will einfach nur einmal
mehr als zwei meter schaffen also kuh
schritt nach vorne genau jetzt machen
wir mal mein gott oh mein gott freude
okay okay danke nein es hat so gut aus
dieses spiel ist so krank schwer ich
krieg das nicht in komm halt dich
einfach auf den verdammten weinen man
also wir spreizen erst mal so ein
bisschen die beine
jetzt stehen wir hier wo mit dem einen
bein auf unserer startlinie mit dem
anderen bein auf unserer besten linie
das heißt ich muss jetzt eigentlich das
linke bein fortziehen also wir ziehen
das mal ran p hier nie genau
0,7 auf wunsch ich sag euch das ist so
krank schwer wenn ihr mir nicht glaubt
dass das so schwer ist dann geht einfach
um mein gott okay denn den habe ich gut
gerettet das heißt wir ziehen jetzt das
bein rand er musste ich einfach nur mal
nach vorne beugen alter das ist doch
kommen kommt ich habe das gefühl ich hab
das gefühl jetzt wird es wird was es
geht was
nein da oben steht sogar 2,3 meter bei
der score sind nur 1,3 meter ich glaube
dass man hier echt am besten voran
kommen wenn man das ganze einfach mal
langsam macht also ich probiere jetzt
mal so voran zu mein gott freunde mein
gott das ist nicht wahr
das macht nicht wirklich das ist nicht
wahr das ist ich war aber wie weit ich
bin ich will bei 2,9 metern ich halte
gerade die ganze zeit wege drückt das
heißt wenn ich das jetzt mal loslassen
bleibt auf jeden fall so auf der stelle
also ich muss irgendwie nach vorne
kommen genauso ich bin bei 3,3 metern
scheiß auf mein abi scheiß auf meinen
bachelor scheiß auf alles was ich bisher
erreicht habe in meinem leben ich bin
einfach nur hier drauf gerade unfassbar
stolz wahrscheinlich sind deine eltern
nicht zufrieden mit dem jungen ein
einfall nach vorne genau 3,9 meter wir
gehen noch so wieder langsam weiter
vorgehen soll bei 4,5 metern so wieder
ein stückchen meter vor der macht jeder
halben spagat freunde was ist denn hier
los auf einmal mit mir ich komme echt
heftig voran also nicht schnell voran
aber ich komme voran und da kann man
sich auch mal den inzwischen durch ich
weiß nicht ob es auf ganz youtube
irgendein video gibt wo jemand dieses
spiel geschafft hat beziehungsweise wo
es jemand wirklich ins ziel geschafft
hat aber ich bin gerade drauf und dran
das verpacken ich bin einfach
tatsächlich wirklich mittlerweile bei
über elfeinhalb meter dass es an der
stelle mich das heutige video ist
allerdings auch beenden meine damen und
herren das ist einfach kein spiel wird
schon mal wirklich ein ganz langes video
machen kann deswegen ist das heutige
video leider ein bisschen kürzer geraten
an der stelle wollte ich allerdings noch
ganz kurz eine kleinigkeit sagen und
zwar werden ab samstag eine neue art von
videos auf meinem kanal kommen keine
sorge freunde es werden jetzt nicht
irgendwelche komplett grundlegend
anderen videos kommen ich werde auch
nicht aufhören mit youtube oder
irgendwas sondern meinen kanal wird sich
nun einer gewissen form ein wenig
verändert
samstag und ich werde eine neue form von
videos hochladen die ich eigentlich ganz
cool finde ich glaube eigentlich alle
von euch werden dass auch feiern also
freuen ich sage schon mal samstag 14 uhr
wird eine video kommen in dem ich euch
das ganze so ein bisschen genauer
erkläre und das wird auch der erste teil
dieser serie sein ja es wäre eine serie
und ich glaube ich habe schon zu viel
verraten aber ab samstag werden eine
neue art von videos kommen auf einem
kanal ich hoffe ihr freut euch darauf
genauso wie ich und jetzt will ich das
video einfach auch mal beenden